[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like the answers to your Bible questions
you come to the right place now here's
your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and Speaker of amazing facts
hello friend would you like to hear an
amazing fact have you ever wished your
pastor sermons were a little shorter how
long should a sermon be 20 minutes 40
minutes do you think an hours too long
if so just be thankful you don't attend
the Cross Church in Mount Dora Florida
in 2014
there 31 year-old pastors set the record
for the longest sermon ever preached
pastor Zack sender began his quest on
Friday November 7 and by Sunday he had
preached for 53 hours and 18 minutes
during the two and a half day homiletic
almera thon Zender preached through 45
of his own sermons and displayed more
than 600 PowerPoint slides along the way
he moved from Genesis to Revelation
while highlighting the theme of divine
faithfulness to comply with Guinness
World Record rules Zender had to speak
before a minimum of 10 people the entire
time and there needed to be two
independent witnesses signing off on its
validity and monitoring his break times
to ensure he met these rules nearly the
whole time
they took little naps during the sermon
toward the end of the event hundreds of
community members came to hear him with
a worn-out voice complete his epic
speech while breaking the previous
record of 48 hours and 31 minutes
the lengthy discourse raised $100,000
for local drug addiction treatment
center with this in mind you might be
interested to consider the most famous
sermon in the world the Sermon on the
Mount presented by Jesus only takes 18
minutes to read stay with his friends
we're going to learn more as amazing
facts brings you this edition of Bible
answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred seven eight hundred four
sixty three seventy to ninety seven now
let's join our host pastor Doug
Batchelor and our co-host pastors Jean
Ross welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live and we've got a fresh
program waiting for you to participate
if you have a Bible question we got
phone lines wide open just give us a
call right now with your Bible question
of course it's a free phone call and
that number 800 God says that's eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven let me give it to you again in
case you weren't ready here we go
call in with your Bible question 800
four six three seven two ninety seven my
name is Doug Batchelor and my name is
John Ross good evening listening frames
and pastor Doug as always let's start
the program with the word of Prayer dear
father in heaven we thank you that we
have this time where we can open up your
word and study together and father we
ask that the Holy Spirit would come and
guide us as we study the Scriptures be
with those listening wherever they might
be they driving their car at home that
your spirit would just guide us into a
clearer and fuller understanding what
the Bible teaches thank you Lord for
your promise to be with us in Jesus name
Amen amen
well you know pastor day usually when a
sermon goes too long and people begin to
doze off or complain that the sermon was
too long it seems like the most
appreciated sermons or sermons that are
on the shorter side and get right to the
point but to motivate people to sit and
listen to a sermon that goes more than
50 hours well there's some committed
members to be involved in that that's
right and you'd be surprised some people
they pick their church based on the past
or in some people quit a church because
the pastor preaches too long you know I
always have the best of intentions when
I get up to preach I plan on making it a
little more short and to the point but I
seem to get hypnotized by my own voice
and
Cheska I go a little long and some
passes always blame the Holy Spirit for
their being enamored by their own voice
but how do you pick a church do you pick
a church based on a pastor friends you
might be interested to know what some of
the top reasons are that people pick a
church of course some people think of
church because it's where their family
when growing up that denomination some
people pick a church because it's close
to the house and convenient some people
pick a church because they love the
architecture this is what a beautiful
building I'd like to go to church there
some they love the music program others
because there is a charismatic preacher
who maybe preaches short sermons some
like that children's program all these
things are important I mean everyone
would like to go to a church that's you
know nice architecture and it's
convenient and good facilities and nice
people loving people good and use a
great children's program and as nice as
those things are none of those things
are the right reason to pick a church
there's only one right biblical reason
to pick a church and it's that the
foundational teachings of that church
are the foundational teachings of Jesus
there are some churches out there that
have this beautiful choirs and music but
you look at their doctrines and they're
diabolical and so you know you have to
look past some of the external niceties
of a church and say what are the
foundational teachings of this
particular church or denomination are
they the teachings of Christ because we
know in the last days there'll be many
that say Lord Lord and they'll say I
never knew you we've got to know that
we're building on the rock so maybe our
friends would like some resources about
that there is a prophecy in the book of
Revelation that deals with the
importance of finding the church that is
teaching the Bible and we have a study
guide it's called the Bride of Christ
and it builds from the theme that we
find in Revelation chapter 12 that is a
free offer for today if you'd like to
call and ask for a study guide called
the Bride of Christ we'd be able to send
it to anybody who calls and asks our
resource phone line is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
the number again is 800
eight three five six seven four seven if
you'd like to receive our free offer
called the Bride of Christ call that
number just ask for it I'll be happy to
send it to you if you have a Bible
question our phone lines are open this
is a good time to call and get your
question on the air tonight the number
here to the studio is 800 four six three
seven two nine seven it's 800 for 63 72
97 that'll bring you here to the studio
with your Bible question I think we're
ready to go to the phone lines our first
caller is Mary Ann listening from
Missouri Mary Ann welcome to the program
um hi hi hi I have a question um this is
about the second half of Leviticus 11
okay and it's not the part about the
food it's the part about like if you
can't touch a dead insect or a dead like
lizard or that kind of thing like for
insects you have to wash your garments
after that and I've never heard of
anybody actually doing that yeah well my
ring I'm sorry go ahead
I'm saying I want to does that apply to
us today or if it if it does if it
doesn't why well most of what you'll
find in these laws there were some laws
about food and what the clean and
unclean food was and then there were
laws about contact and the laws about
contact are mostly comments and
sanitation you know if your kids come in
from playing with a puppy you'd always
tell them wash their hands before they
eat the you know and there's some
animals in particular that you know the
Bible says that they should wash for and
and those are typically the unclean
animals I think it says here you know if
you've got a mouse for instance and you
you go to use a pot you look and as hell
man a mouse has been in the pot well you
sure want to clean that pot and I think
that's part of what's in here any vessel
into which any of these things fall
you'll break their there were some
vessels it couldn't be cleaned because
in the old clay you know mouse urine or
something like that would permeate the
pores it's a porous material if it was a
metal pot you could clean it if it was
play you throw it out so most of it it
says sanitation laws and of course
touched a dead body you'd be unclean and
because you know who knows decomposition
could have set in and it's not clean so
I think most people try to follow these
things by this common sense yeah and of
course when we read about this this was
to the children of Israel during their
wilderness wanderings and these laws
applied even before they were
established in the Promised Land they
didn't have the ability to go wash your
hands with soap and water if you were to
touch a dead animal or some kind of a
unclean insect or something are we today
and if you pick up even a spite I know
my wife doesn't like spiders and if
there is a dead spider and she somehow
has to move it you know there's some
kind of a paper towel involved and they
smell washing the conclusion of that
these are things that we just kind of
take for granted but then God was
clearly specifying these are some of the
basic principles we also have to
remember that the children of Israel I
just come out of slavery in Egypt and
things are a little different now that
they were wandering in the wilderness
and they need to learn these important
principles spiders don't bother me to
earwigs okay they will obey I guess not
a white identify right here week this
creeps me out sure did that help answer
that for you Marian well Michael Cain
and verse 25 it says if you lift up
their dead body I you have you must wash
your garments yeah and now it doesn't
mean that as soon as you touch something
like that you needed to you know drop
everything and head for the river you
couldn't come into the temple you
weren't supposed to be in your you know
abide in the camp but yeah if you're
touching any of these dead things they
say go wash God had them be very
particular about cleanliness and
throughout history the Jewish
communities have always been a lot safer
when plagues swept through Europe
because of their careful sanitation laws
so there are some of it we don't
understand now but the Lord just kind of
gave them some blanket rules if they
were unclean animals especially wash if
you touch them you know we do it another
version that Bible I forgot where it is
says if you don't wash your garments
then you're going to be cut off from
your people okay yeah I think he means
those who refuse to practice these
things would be cut off meaning
sometimes cut off meant they'd be
executed sometimes cut off meant that
they'd be banished from the kingdom and
if someone was saying look I'm not going
to observe the laws of holiness impurity
they'd banish them you know we do have a
study guide that talks about these
health principles and it's called God's
free health plan it deals more with the
animals and deals with food but still
some of these other principles of
Sanitation is even touched on they're in
the study guide we'll be happy to send
it to anybody who calls an ass the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
you can ask for the study guide called
God's free health plan will be happy to
send it to anybody who calls and asks
and if you have a Bible question our
phone line here to the studio this
evening is 804 six three seven two nine
seven I'm going to say it again so get
ready here it is 800 four six three
seven two nine seven it's a good time to
give us a call and we'll get your Bible
collation on the air tonight a next call
is reasoner listening from Charlotte
North Carolina recently welcome to the
program I have two questions tonight one
is Genesis 1:16 on the fourth day you
see a bunch of stores created and thanks
to the Hubble telescope we now know that
stars have solar systems and planets
revolving around the first question is
why wasn't Satan and his angels sent to
one of those planets to establish their
government and leave rather than be put
here all right well why would Satan cast
to the earth and you'll find that
mentioned in Revelation chapter 12 the
reason Satan was sent to the earth is
because as the devil rebelled against
God and he went through the universe and
probably appealed to the other
intelligent creatures that they would
have an audience with him and that they
would trust him they all rejected Satan
and they put God first many of them were
tested
loyalty our world failed the test of
loyalty Adam and Eve decided to listen
to the devil instead of God and that's
why Satan was cast down to the earth
because our first parents chose to
listen to the devil when he said go
ahead and eat from the forbidden tree
God said don't eat from it Bible says
whoever you obey in Romans 6 that's
whose servant you are and so that's why
he was sent here because he had people
that were showed him allegiance okay
second question all of the beasts and
Daniel can be traced back to one of
Noah's son except for the beast of
represents Rome which fun would that be
have defended from now what do you mean
that the beasts and Daniel are traced
back to one of Noah's sons I'm not sure
gaming in other words like the Medes and
the Persians came from you know if you
look at that map in almost bibles yeah
you can identify the son they came yeah
what iswhat you saying you the what if
he is hereditary
yeah the hierarchy of the different
empires I'm not sure but did Rome come
from
Japheth it's believed yes more Japheth
area now remember Rome you have these
ten tribes coming from the northern area
and kind of carved up or overcame the
various other kingdoms and then
eventually Rome at least modern Rome
came from that they probably came that
talks more from the Rome came from the
West so that would have been the
descendants of Japheth that moved into
that area that we know more so as West
in Europe today okay thanks a lot all
right thank you appreciate your question
kind of thing if you have a study guide
on that I don't know if we have do we
have anything on Tower of Babel that
might talk about that a little bit
we do have understanding tongues and
it's connection to the Tower of Babel
and how we how people must understand
what that is all about you know that's a
free offer we'll be happy to give it to
you reasoner or anybody wanting to learn
more this is more specific about tongues
but it is connected with
because that's where you had the
confusion of languages the number to
call is 883 five six seven four seven
and you can ask for the book called
understanding tongues and will be able
to send it to anybody who calls and asks
yes precedent yeah I just I didn't I'd I
googled it as they sit ok Arianna s'en
it does look like the the Roman tribes
originally descended from Japheth I was
just double-checking that I think that's
correct alright so thank you for your
call reasoner if you have a Bible
question the phone line to call is eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven that's eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven annex Kali is
Leah listening from Michigan
Leah welcome to the program good
afternoon thank you so much for having
me I've called many times my breasts I
didn't through well glad you made it
okay quick question in Hebrews chapter
six are starting to verse 4 it talks
about people who tasted God you know who
certified their own students and they're
always I interpreted that to leave this
without repentance and I'm calling me
because I have a loved one when the
praise died years ago gave Jesus Kartik
all the praying for his testimony
deliverance from you know his life
issues and over the last decade he is
totally denounced God he went over to
one of the eastern lands studied
religion that come back speaking
something totally against God through
Christ Jesus and so my question is if
it's you know to continue to pray for
him to come back to God because based on
the scripture are interpreted at it
beyond repentance and all I were to curb
it in it yeah well I would be careful
not to assume that he may be
demonstrating no repentance now but you
know the story of the prodigal son when
that prodigal son he was raised in the
father's house he knew the father and
and but he turned his back on it all and
he went to live in this totally
reprobate living but the father never
ceased to probably pray for him
and he came to his senses now this
friend is uh you know he's turned away
and there may be no outward evidence but
you never know what God might do in a
person's heart and the Bible says all
things are possible with God so if
you're going to make the mistake of not
praying long enough for somebody or
praying too long I take the risk of
including them what have you got to lose
in this book sure I'm misinterpreting it
it doesn't mean he can repeat it
well I think Paul is describing somebody
here assuming Paul wrote Hebrews and
this is Hebrews 6 verse 4 it says it's
impossible for those who were once
enlightened and have tasted the heavenly
gift and to become partakers of the Holy
Spirit and have tasted the good word of
God and the powers of the age to come if
they fall away to renew them again to
repentance since they crucify again for
themselves the Son of God Paul says
saying if they persist in turning away
from everything good what more can God
give them so it doesn't mean that that
person can never be turned around by
coming back to their senses but as long
as they continue to persist in rebellion
God has nothing more to offer them
besides the best I can bring forth to
continue to pray for him yeah you know
look in the Bible if the story of
Manasseh King Manasseh was you know he's
raised by Hezekiah godly King godly
father turned away from the Lord and you
know for years was just a wicked King
brought sort of worship pagan gods like
your friend he turned away from Jehovah
but he went through some trials and he
turned back to the god of his youth and
matter fact God answered has a guy's
prayers for his son long after Hezekiah
was dead so keep praying for someone you
never know it might be the final hours
of their life they turn around we have a
book called beyond mercy that talks
about the unpardonable son what it is
what it isn't and how one ought to
respond to that and we'll be able to
send it to anybody who calls and asks
the phone line to our resource is eight
hundred eight thirty five six seven four
seven just call that phone line answer
the book called beyond mercy
and we'll be able to send it to anybody
who calls if you have a Bible question
our phone line here to the studio is
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven it's 800 four six three seven
two nine seven Thank You Leah
the next call is Ronald listening in the
Bronx New York
Ronald welcome to the program yeah I
like to know I like to know um I have a
question for you about Queenie quitting
Luke chapter 21 verse 25 and I'd like to
know what does it mean when it says the
stress of Nations Republic or Rex Ric
with thee
alright let me read this to our friends
talking about and this is Jesus speaking
here he's talking about signs of the
second coming and he said there will be
signs in the Sun and the moon and the
stars and on the earth distress of
Nations with perplexity the sea and the
waves roaring and it goes on to say
men's hearts failing them for fear
distress of Nations with perplexity that
means that there is a general fear among
the nations of the world regarding the
things that are coming upon the earth
and it says their hearts are failing
them for fear perplexity means there's
confusion everyone is confused about how
to solve the problems you know right now
the nations of the world are trying to
solve these major problems by putting a
band-aid on a bullet wound there's very
little that they can do to deal with
some of these massive problems now some
of read where it says signs in the Sun
Moon and stars for those that are
listening North America you know we're
getting ready to have a what do they say
once every hundred years they've got a
on Eclipse that totally trans sex the
continent and it can be you know total
eclipse across North America and a lot
of people are flying to different cities
where they can be at the epicenter of
that and someone asked me is this one of
the signs in the Sun and the moon and
the stars because in Eclipse affects the
Seven the moon and I don't think so I
don't think God is gauging his prophecy
calendar based upon you know where the
eclipse has happened because they have
eclipses every year in different parts
of the world
yeah but they say that on that on this
the son would not give us light before
the great and terrible day of the Lord a
comb yeah well which yeah but that's
happened with several eclipses and but
you are correct the Bible says that the
moon will look like blood the Sun will
be turned to darkness and that actually
happened once in history in North
America was that 1833 1533 was the
meteor shower fooling them stars that's
right when the dark day was 717 run
after the Lisbon earthquake Friuli 79
after 90 or something yeah they had what
they called the dark day it's kind of
interesting for no explicable reason in
the middle of the day the Sun on the
eastern seaboard of the u.s. just went
dark and it wasn't the Eclipse and
there's been all kinds of theories but
they never did figured out that they the
chickens even went to roost at noon some
said that historically this was a dark
day but the Sun Moon and stars
you know Sun going dark moon turning to
blood started falling from heaven most
things will happening in quick
succession before the second coming
because it also says in Revelation and
the heavens will be part as a scroll now
that hasn't happened yet so yeah the
date for that was May 19 1780 1780 M and
you can actually read about it I just
looked it up writing on online Google
Wikipedia talks about New England's dark
day and gives you some of these stars
which is very interesting yeah that's
quite a story
when they talk about the trepidation
they was saying um that I was here
little news they say they didn't know
what to do about Syria and Israel you
know well there is great distress not to
Syrian Israel but you know right now the
u.s. is contemplating a military strike
against North Korea North Korea keeps
rattling its nuclear sword and testing
missiles and saying we're trying to
develop a missile they can reach the
u.s. that's pretty threatening language
so but this is not the first time in
history that international leaders have
been perplexed or fearful of their
neighbors and so I do think the stakes
are higher now than they've ever been
because the weapons now
are more deadly the economy of the world
is more integrated now than it ever has
been and I think people are looking for
an international leader and that's you
know what revelation 13 says that
they'll be looking for international
leader
thank you very much Ronald hope that
helps a little now we have a book that
talks about that you might offer yeah we
have we have a study guide on the second
coming actually gives some signs
associated with the coming of Jesus
deals with these very verses it's called
the ultimate deliverance and that is
free to anybody who calls and asks the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
you can answer the study guide called
the ultimate deliverance you can also go
online to the amazing facts website
amazing facts o RG or calm and you can
sign up for the free amazing facts study
guide series and you can actually read
all of this or this lesson and many
others dealing with different important
Bible themes well you know pastor Doug I
think we're coming up on our amid break
here probably not a good idea to take
colleges yet we'll end up having to cut
that short but there are some
interesting things that amazing facts is
doing in the arena of upcoming prophecy
presentations I know this is a little
ways away but might be good to let our
friends know about it you're going to be
in November you're going to be on the
East Coast during a special series
called foundations of faith that's kind
of building on some of these important
Protestant themes that we see presented
in Scripture and elsewhere yes
absolutely of course I think many people
know in the headlines that the October
31 is the 500 year anniversary from what
they call the birth of the Protestant
Reformation when Luther nailed his
famous 95 theses on the doors of the
Wittenberg and in this year several of
the leading Protestant denominations and
the Orthodox and Catholic Church are
making statements of reconciliation
saying you know the Protestant
Reformation is over and that's that's
pretty interesting in the light of
prophecy because the reasons for the
Protestant Reformation have not changed
the thing is that Luther protested
against the Orthodox churches have not
renounced and so you're wondering what
happened did the Protestants cease
protesting and wanting to get back to
the by
so we're going to be talking about
foundations of our faith right after
that event on November 3 through 11 we
will be broadcasting live of course on
the Internet it'll be on the Hope
channel which can be seen on Direct TV
it'll be on 3abn which can be seen on
the Dish Network it'll be seen on
amazing facts TV which can be seen on
the g19 satellite dish and they're you
know around the world via Facebook but
everyone will be able to see the
foundations of faith it will be nine
presentations we will be talking about
scripture faith what does it mean to be
saved by grace the variations between
tradition and Bible I'll start telling
your friends about that now a matter of
fact I believe we have a website yes and
I'm just looking right now if you want
to get more information about that go to
the amazing facts website amazing facts
about our G and we have a big banner
it's actually on the homepage you click
on that it says foundations of faith and
we'll give you a lot more information
now don't go away friends we're just
going to get a drink of water that's
what that sound is and then we're going
to take a break and be right back with
more Bible questions
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment I really wanted to
start a new devotional habit but life
got in the way
next thing I know we're months into the
new year and I'm like what's the point
of starting then I saw 365 amazing
answers to big Bible questions each day
is a single study you can start anywhere
on any day and not miss a thing their
crisp clear and enlightening get yours
today by calling 855-578-6767 incredible
stories from all over the globe of lives
that are being changed and hearts that
are being transformed by the power of
the word and none of it could happen
without your teamwork with this ministry
god bless you
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 free resources
my name is Doug Batchelor my name is
John Ross and we are ready to go to the
phone lines I next call is Robert Rob
he's listening from Florida
Robert welcome to the program all right
how are you all doing doing great thank
you for calling I just wanted to say
thank you very much for having this
program I think it's a wonderful thing
and I love you all well likewise and how
we'll help you is going to ask you
before you question
pastor Doug and I were just talking are
you in Stanford Florida or Sanford
Florida
si n Sanford where Trayvon Martin was oh
yeah we know where that was well or is
we were there the meeting there this
year was it this year not even to say I
think it would water yeah alright so we
know we are it's a birthday so my
question was simply about Satan I want
to know this creature has plagued my
imagination and I'm not sure at real the
caller earlier mentioned it I just want
to know who he is
all right well Satan the word Satan
actually in Hebrew it means adversary
and you know sometimes he's called as
the devil the evil one Beelzebub
apollyon how many number names are there
for thee the devil in the by the serpent
the dragon anyway there was a beautiful
angel named Lucifer and he was the
highest of God's creations and some were
in the remote recesses of time a Lucifer
began to regret see God makes all of his
creatures completely free and Lucifer
began to wish he had the power of God
and and whatever his reasons might be he
began to rebel against God and to
undermine God's leadership and through
pride this cosmic war broke out and
Lucifer persuaded one third of the
angels to follow him and ultimately
there was a war in heaven you read about
that in Revelation 13 Satan who is a
spiritual being like God is he and his
forces were cast to the earth and they
are the authors of all the evil that
happens and virtually every religion
recognizes that there are powers of good
and powers of evil the Bible gives them
more precise names and there are
two-thirds of the good angels now God
could just destroy the devil he's got
that power but if he just destroys the
devil without allowing Satan to
demonstrate what the result of his
rebellion is his rebellion will just
keep cropping up
and so God kind of had to let Lucifer's
rebellion play out it's playing out here
in our world this battle between good
and evil God said I want to show you
what I'm like I will come to the earth
in the form of a man and that was Jesus
and he came to show us what God is like
to show us the love of God well and at
the cross he battled really going all
well you know what I just wanted to tell
you though I got a book here I stand
from the same thing that y'all are doing
now this is where I got this information
and it says Martin Luther I think you
had mentioned that just before
the or during the commercial break yeah
he wrote that he proclaims him to be st.
Satan pray for us for you alone are holy
go and would you say to do God and get
grace for yourself if you want to get me
all straightened out I say physician to
yourself I'm not sure if he's a man
though now Lucifer is the Bible says in
Ephesians 6 that Satan is I know about
I'm in Satan though now Lucifer well
Satan is Lucifer it says two names same
thing oh I didn't I didn't know that his
name was later I don't know when he was
a good angel he was called Lucifer when
he was cast out of heaven his name was
Satan but we've got a DVD that talks
about this in detail that gives the
whole story about where Lucifer and
Satan came from it's called the cosmic
conflict and I believe it might be on
youtube you can watch it for free on
youtube just type in cosmic conflict
you'll see it I don't believe stuff you
know what I mean you can't believe what
you see and reading though well this is
if you believe the Bible at all and I do
well this is all based on the Bible and
the Scriptures are given through the
whole program and we do have a study
guide specifically dealing with this
called did God create a devil and it
gets all the Bible verses dealing with
the subject of Wilson came from where
did Lucifer come from where did Satan
come from of course Lucifer you Satan
how the fold occurred at least what the
Bible reveals about that I think you'll
find that very helpful Robert to receive
our free study guide just call us on our
resource phone number that's eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and you can answer the study guide
called did God create a devil and we'll
send that to you and also take a look at
that DVD prepared the video prepared by
amazing facts called cosmic conflict and
that's also a summary of some important
Bible teachings on that if you have a
Bible question a phone line here at the
studio is eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven that's 800 four 63
72 97 next holy is Eddy listening in
Michigan Eddy welcome to the program
thank you very much god bless you how
are you good thank you for calling good
I know that Jesus Christ was a part of
the Trinity and um my question is
in the Bible Jesus Christ said himself
that only the father knew when his
second coming what happened so I was
wondering if you could shed some light
on that for me
yeah when Jesus was talking about the
second coming and pastor Ross assists
the Matthew or the Luke version he said
no man knows the day or the hour but my
father over not even the son um but when
Jesus was on the earth and you can read
about this in Colossians Christ laid
aside his part of his divinity I mean
obviously when Jesus was a baby on earth
you know he didn't have all the power
and the knowledge of the cosmos swirling
around in his little baby head he had to
learn to walk and talk like other babies
and so Jesus when he was on earth he
said look I the father's not even
revealed that to me now he obviously
knows now his bed but as a man he didn't
know the date of course if he didn't
know the date what would he had told the
disciples you know I'm coming in 2025
they would say 2025 dating another
dating method back then it would have
been meaningless to them right yeah the
verse you're looking at is you could
find it in two places Matthew 24 verse
36 and also in mark chapter 13 verse 32
but I think he knows now he's at the
right hand of the Father so once once he
went back to once he went to heaven back
to heaven and he knew then yes once
again he's got his all-knowing just God
one of the definitions of God is he's
omniscient he's all-knowing and Jesus is
all-knowing now okay I think you
appreciate your question Eddie you know
you might also enjoy that study guide
talking about the second coming of
Christ called the ultimate deliverance
and we'll send it to you for free if you
call and ask it's eight hundred eight
thirty five six seven four seven after
the study guide on the second coming
called the ultimate deliverance and if
you have a Bible question I fall in line
here to the studio is eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven not too
late to pick up the phone and give us a
call we have about twenty more minutes
left to take Bible questions the number
again is 800 four six three seven two
nine seven and we have Jason who is
listening in Utah Jason welcome to the
program hello
thanks for calling and your question
well I got an uncooperative spouse and I
don't know what to do it I'm actually an
Adventist and he wanted to be and now
she has no desire for anything well if
so what do you do if you're a believer
and you have a spouse and they're not
cooperating with you they're not in a
supporting your faith you know it tells
us in is it first Peter chapter 3 where
it says that if there is a if there's a
woman and she's married to a husband
he's not a believer that while they
behold your chaste behavior coupled with
fear they behold your reverence that you
can win them now not only is that true
of a woman winning an unbelieving
husband it's true of a husband winning
to the Lord an unbelieving wife and I
think you can also read in 1st
Corinthians chapter 7 we actually had
this question at the men's retreat we
were at this weekend that if you've got
a believing husband or wife and your
spouse does not believe do all you can
to stay with them and it says you know
how do you know oh man if you will not
win your wife or woman your husband by
your behavior by your love by your your
patience and it may not happen right
away the verses you're referring today
pastor degrees 1st Corinthians chapter 7
if you want to start reading it's
probably from about verse 13 through all
the way to verse 16 dealing with this
situation of a believer and an
unbelieving they married how do they
relate to one another
tremendous counsel right you in
Scripture we have a lesson that deals
with the keys to a happy marriage yes
some good principles from the Bible in
there as well that is a study guide that
amazing facts is put together if you'd
like to receive that the number to call
is eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven you can answer the
study guide called keys to a happy
marriage
hope that helps Jason if again if you'd
like to learn more about that we have a
book too that talks about marriage I
think there is worse and remarriage I
think there's a lot of good principles
in that too Jason
if you have a Bible question of four -
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven eight hundred four sixty
three seventy two 97 we have Alex
listening in Michigan Alex welcome to
the program good evening guys thank you
for being there well thank you we're
delighted to be part of the of the Bible
study yeah well ty it's it's such a
blessing you guys be in there you know
because we all need understanding and
when we lack understanding it's great to
reach out and get the help we need but
um my question for you this evening is
about ex chapter 5 yeah I want to
understand a little bit more about how
it came that Ananias and Sapphira lied
to the Holy Spirit I mean I'm I'm only
can think that they committed by the
word amount that they were going to do
something and they felt led of the Holy
Spirit to do it and they said to the
Holy Spirit we're going to do this and
then they reneged on the deal is that
what your interpretation is of why they
ended up being killed because of lying
to the Holy Spirit or how did they do
that well I tell you what let me read
the first two verses of Acts to our
listening friends and they can get the
context of this but a certain man this
is acts 5 verse 1 but a certain man
named Ananias with Sapphira his wife
sold a possession and they kept packed
back part of the proceeds his wife also
being aware of it and they brought a
certain part and laid it at the Apostles
feet now what they did is people were
then donating a property to help spread
the gospel and they went through the
charade of saying you know we sold our
property for $10,000 and we're giving it
all to the Lord well in reality they
sold it for 20 or something and they
lied and they said the Holy Spirit told
them don't do that that's dishonest but
they resisted the impression of the Holy
Spirit to be honest and they made like
they were giving everything but it was
hypocrisy and it was a big lie and his
wife said yeah let's pretend we're
giving the whole thing but let's keep
some of it for ourselves they could have
done whatever they wanted Peter says
that in the story said while it was
yours you could have done whatever you
wanted but don't lie because you're
lying to the Holy Spirit we didn't know
how much he sold it for but the Holy
Spirit did and they were impressed by
the spear
not to be deceptive but they resisted
the Holy Spirit and they lied anyway and
they both drop dead it was a pretty
serious offense in the early days of the
church because here they were seeing
miracles everywhere they saw the power
of God and so their sentence was more
severe so I don't know if that answers
what you're asking Alex it does it does
and I was going to ask one other brief
question and editor if you could
spending um I'm I'm struggling because
I'm remarried and once in awhile I'm
like I'm in sin because I'm ray married
but I would like to know if you could
send me one of your guides that would
give me some instruction on that and you
know
yeah we'll we'll be happy to send you
well you could actually have both we
have the book called marriage divorce
and remarriage and then we have the book
on keys for a hundred happy marriage
yeah it's a little simple call resource
number and they'll just take your
address and send it to you and nobody
will harass you the number to create
with that be ready to run a families
here it is it's 883 five six seven four
seven that's the phone number 883 five
six seven four seven you can ask for the
book called marriage divorce and
remarriage and while you add it after
the study guide on marriage called keys
to a happy marriage and we will send
that to you Alex or anyone who called
and asked wants to study the subject
further our next call is Steve listening
in Nebraska Steve welcome to the program
good hi thanks for calling I just a
little fuzzy on a couple of things I've
come from a family of multiple face for
getting a straight entry not easy I fell
away from the from the cries for a good
number of years my question is how do
you how can you be sure that Christ will
accept you back when you can't there's
no way you're going to remember all the
sins that you may have created our
committed over the years to repent right
does that make sense yeah but what makes
you think that you've got to remember
all the sins you've committed because
I've been told over the years that in
order to regain the grace of God or get
back in into into the faith properly you
must read
and all the things that you've committed
but when is when you've been away for so
many years there's no way you're going
to remember all that
well repenting know all the sins you've
committed is something it's really very
simple it doesn't mean give God a list
as first of all God remembers and better
than you do
it would mean just you know start with
the Ten Commandments so there's a list
of ten that's real easy to remember and
say Lord I repent of my sins I lied I
have maybe you stole maybe there's been
impure thoughts or just whatever they
are say Lord forgive me of my sins the
Bible that doesn't mean remember every
exact incident and you know what if you
think you're forgetting something major
then just pray and say Lord if I'm
forgetting something the Holy Spirit
will show me because God wants to not
make it hard for you he wants to make it
easy for you to come back to him so he's
not going to say well I'm going to you
forgot this one sin out of twenty and so
you're not going to make it if you
sincerely want to come to the Lord right
now and get in the beginning you can
come right now the Bible says whoever
comes to me I will in no wise cast out
and the Bible promise also and this is
first John chapter 1 verse 9 if we
confess our sins he is faithful and just
to forgive us our sins and cleanse us
from all unrighteousness just start out
by saying Lord I've been a big sinner
and I'm sorry for all of my sins you say
Lord I can't remember them all that's an
honest repentance ok hey I why I'm in my
mid-thirties now and I walked away when
I was in my late teen well I'm glad that
you're going to be walking back Steve is
that right yes hey how could I pray that
you now yes Father in Heaven I just am
so thankful Steve call tonight and I
believe there are many others like him
that want to know how to find their way
back Lord you've made a promise in your
word that if we draw near to you you
will draw near to us and Steve is
drawing near to you and just as the
father ran to meet the prodigal son we
know that you'll run to embrace Steve
and others that have drifted away and
want to come back and Lord they're sorry
for their sins and they repent and they
confess that and now give them your
spirit and new life because that's why
Jesus came and we pray in his name
amen amen I just had one other quick
question one of your other callers
actually just brought it to mine yeah
in regards to the whole Lucifer Satan
thing like I said I come from a family
of multiple different days yeah
so it's a that one's a little bit
confusing as well as wondering if about
getting a little bit more information on
that we will send you two things one is
we will be happy to send you a lesson
called three steps to heaven
because you and I just talked about what
do I need to do to come back to the Lord
so we'll send you that and then we'll
send you the lesson that's called did
God create a devil it is a really clear
to get I like it it's got neat pictures
and it's well Illustrated plus it's got
all the Bible verses and if you call the
number pastor Ross is going to give you
you tell them you want those two things
say I want three steps to heaven and I
want did God create a devil the left
handle where the devil came from and
will submit to you all right Steve the
number to Kol is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven you're
going to ask for three steps to heaven
it's a little book we'll send that to
you and also the study guide called did
God create a devil and they'll get them
and get that in the mail right away and
you'll be able to read through that and
I think you'll find it very helpful and
for any of our friends listening out
there if you want to study these
subjects more I want to remind you
amazing facts does have a free Bible
correspondence program if you'd call
that same number eight hundred eighty
three five six seven four seven and say
I'm interested in the amazing facts
Bible correspondence program will be
able to send you a series of lessons you
can go through them you can study them
you can send in your answers and we'll
have somebody grade it and send you the
next set of lessons so this is just a
great way to study the Bible and cut a
clear understanding of these important
teachings our next caller is Tommy and
he's listening in Tennessee Tommy
welcome to the program hi Tommy you're
on the air thank you for calling oh
thank you I live up on a mountain and I
can see the stars tight they're very
beautiful well bless your heart your
back east
so we still have the Sun up that's the
only star we see in California but how
can we help you out tonight just a short
question people that have not audibly
heard the name of Jesus or had the
chance to hear his name or being witness
to or whatever or not audibly heard his
name and maybe saved there will be some
of course you know the reason we send
missionaries around the world is there's
a lot of people who will be lost because
they don't know the truth and Jesus said
the truth sets you free but then the
Lord was very careful to say that many
will come from the east and the west and
sit down in the kingdom with Abraham
Isaac and Jacob there may be some who
have lived up to the light that they had
that God through his spirit and angel
spoke to their hearts and they tried yes
even Paul says where is it romans
chapter one he said that even the
barbarians even the Gentiles they have
an inner voice that knows through the
works of creation I can't be the Creator
yeah and so those who have followed all
the light that God gave them and they
sincerely sought after what was right I
believe you're going to see some people
in the kingdom by the grace of God even
though they didn't know about Jesus now
a couple of examples of this would be
Jesus said that name and the leper is
going to be in the kingdom and then also
he talked about a Phoenician Widow that
he lied to live with could amend the the
Jews in Nazareth got very upset with
Jesus suggesting that these Gentiles
could be saved and they didn't know all
the truth and they want to throw Jesus
off the cliff and there are some
churches today to say unless a person
knows the name of Jesus they can't go to
heaven but what do you doing Noah you
know there's a lot of people they didn't
know the name of Jesus back then so you
know the Lord is going to save people if
we walk in the light that he gives us
but obviously if they don't hear the
gospel then they can't believe they it's
going to be a lot harder
I guess wondered in some of the remotest
areas of the earth if God spiritually
reveals himself yeah let me just give
you an example I've been to Australia
several times and the Aborigines there
were sort of cut off from much of the
world for maybe even thousands of years
and you know we know of no missionaries
going there until after Captain Cook
I have heard preachers say that means
that every Aborigine that was born would
be lost because they didn't have a
missionary I don't believe that I think
that God have exceptions and that there
are people that their hearts were right
they sought after God he tried to urge
them with his spirit they saw God
through creation even David said the
heavens declare the glory of God so I
think there'll be some people we're
going to see in the kingdom and they're
there by the grace of Jesus but they may
not have known the gospel correct and I
agree with you 100%
well good I know that what I said make
some people mad but thank you very much
appreciate your call Henry McDonald a
Elbert listening from Queens New York
Albert welcome to the program oh thank
you very much god bless you thank you
for calling your question yes I have a
question on I was calling about
Christian churches regarding like
denominations if you're returning to
church and you know like I haven't been
to church in a while and I'm trying to
find you know the right church but I
don't know what their beliefs are I'm
very confused and you know sometimes
when you go to the church they'll be
preaching about something that everybody
you agree on but you don't know what the
disagreements are on stuff right so I
was just pretty much trying to find out
where I can get that information if
there's any information on there
unbiased information
well I'm biased I mean if you ask me I
would tell you to go to my denomination
but that that's normal well I would
worry about a pastor if you called him
up and said what church should I join
they told you to join a different
denomination than theirs mean you think
what are you doing here then right
exactly that's why it's so tough
to find you know III don't know what
denominations out there you know why
there's so many denominations if you
know let's say everybody believes
everything the Bible sort of a hundred
percent what's the difference is in the
know first of all keep in mind that the
devil has worked over time in trying to
divide Christianity but you're gonna
have to study for yourself jesus
promises seek and you'll find could I
recommend a Bible study series it's free
we will send you a Bible study series
that will have you go through the main
teachings of Christianity like there's
one that just talks about what is the
role of Scripture in the Christians life
and then the taught another one talks
about who is God do we believe in the
Trinity or if so where does that come
from and it's a great series it's free
but if you'd like we'll send you that
and then you just compare it with the
Bible and see if it matches up if it
doesn't then I'd be suspicious but do
you need to go by what the scriptures
say could ask you one last question and
it's related to it um we like like
things that I hear like the Book of
Enoch and these other things and
supposedly there's a book of Judas that
was taken out and put in or something
like that um are those are those just
myths or yeah those books you know of
course the book of Judas was a
concoction it's been it's an apocryphal
book it's been manufactured the Book of
Enoch is a book that was probably
developed during the time of the
Babylonian captivity the books that
you've got in the Bible are the ones
that were recognized by the Bible
writers as inspired and I'd stick with
that matter of fact what you're asking
albert is in the first study guide what
did you call the number and after the
amazing fact study series we'll send it
to you for free the number to call is
eight hundred eight thirty five six
seven four seven that is our resource
phone line and you can just ask to
enroll free in the amazing fact study
guide series again that number is 885
six seven four seven ask to be a part of
the amazing facts Bible study series the
Correspondence School and we'll be happy
to send you I think we send the first
four or five lessons you go
through that and then we'll send you the
next hey thank you so much for your
question Albert I really do hope you
follow up you'll be sounds like you're
searching you seek you'll find I see
we've got to Henry and Reggie waiting on
the line please give us a call next week
we're running out of air time
don't go away friends we do have a few
closing announcements that are very
important and we really hope you go
visit the amazing facts website and
that's simply amazing fact dot o-r-g one
of the most popular Christian websites
there if you've been blessed by the
program it's only people like you to
keep us on please donate help us keep
doing this study together again next
week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
can't get enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vor G are you wondering what
lies ahead in human history or what
piece of world events are harbingers of
the end are you ready for the coming
crisis landmarks of prophecy offers
clearer answers to your most pressing
questions presented by pastor Doug
Batchelor landmarks of prophecy is a
contemporary video Bible study adventure
designed for today's audiences
presenting the landmark themes of the
Bible and a bright and compelling way
helping you understand the Bible better
and giving you knowledge to pinch the
future with confidence landmarks of
prophecy contains over 30 hours of
exciting video presentations on six DVDs
plus bonus question and answer sessions
giving you cue insight into what lies
next in human history if you'd like
practical tools to help you thrive and
survive in the here and now get
landmarks of prophecy start your epic
Bible study adventure with landmarks of
prophecy today by calling
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF act 0 RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 FX 0 RG did you enjoy
this program make sure to tell your
family and friends tune in next time for
more Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible questions
you